à orléans 1547 on écoutait ceci et on
découvrait cette toute nouvelle bâtisse
un joyau d'architecturé moderne
aujourd'hui qualifiée de style
renaissance et appartenant à un riche
avocat de la ville cabu était un
important avocats des châtelets et il
décide alors de 15 152 se construire un
grand hôtel particulier qui en effet
répond aux goûts le plus moderne de la
renaissance
finalement c'est un bâtiment
contemporain ce serait un mail même
geste architectural que aujourd'hui
faire construire un bâtiment très
contemporain là il montre son pouvoir et
son goût d'esthète en construisant un
bâtiment comme celui-ci ce très bel
hôtel particulier sera un peu modifié au
fil des siècles mais subira surtout un
traumatisme majeur lors de la seconde
guerre mondiale en 1940 les
bombardements réduit ce presque à néant
cette exceptionnelle édifice trois
musées ont été détruits à cette occasion
dont l'hôtel cabut donc il a fallu de ne
pas recevez quelques pièces
extraordinaires notamment le trésor de
neuvy en sus dias a pu être évacuée est
toujours visible il s'agit d'un des
principaux trésors gaulois conservés en
france
vingt et un des plus importants dans le
monde l'hôtel cabu renaît donc de ses
cendres il ya 50 ans et vient à nouveau
d'être l'objet d'un chantier de
rénovation
long de 6 années on peut à nouveau
admirer ses façades et ses collections
notamment celles dédiées à jeanne d'arc
comportant un portrait réalisé à la fin
du xvième siècle qui datent de 1581
qu'elle conservait à orléans à l'hôtel
cabu et qui a servi de modèle par la
suite à tous les portraits de jeanne
d'arc dès qu'il a fallu représenter
jeanne d'arc
on avait un gabarit on savait comment la
représenter
en sortant de cet écrin vous n'oublierez
pas d'admirer le bâtiment qui lui fait
face
l'hôtel des créneaux autres réminiscence
du temps béni de la renaissance
non